Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to a video where I show you something
that makes me laugh, pretty much everyday now.
I-I actually don't know what I'm gonna call this video because...
I-I just am going to show you this sub-Reddit that I browse a lot,
and it's called "r/PeopleFuckingDying."
And that sounds bad; you may think that I'm doing the 50/50 challenge
or the "Try Not to Cringe" or the "Try Not to Puke" Challenge.
But... y-you'll see what I mean.
So this first one here...
"MOm DEcIdEs tO KiLL hER sOn".
They're always named like this...
and this is what it is.
*walking*
*sOn fUcKinG dIES*
Oh no!
That's not the best example, but God it makes me laugh...
It's-It's-It's something like this... where the title is something horrific
and then the end result is something... not quite so bad.
It's clickbait, that's what this is!
It's the clickbait sub-Reddit! *Mark laughing*
*high pitched* That's what it is!
DoG ViCioUsLY BiTEs FinGeR oFF.
*happiness* Aw... *laughter*
And then you get cute stuff like that.
Like, it's a mixture, it's a strange mixture of like,
people getting hurt, but not too bad,
and stuff like this.
I love this sub-Reddit. It's always an adventure.
"InnoCenT MAn MAULEd by VIcIous Pack OF fELineS".
And it's just... aw
It's just ca-hAhaHAhaH
Look at him bapping!
Oh, you BAPPY WAPPY!
Oh, you bappy wappy.
Uh, don't lick the kitty. *laughing*
*Coughs up hairball*
Don't do that.
"WOlf AtTaCKs MaN,
VIcIOusLY ChewING His FAcE OfF".(Something Chica would do)
*waits for cuteness*
*Mark's patented cute things laugh*
Oh, that's so CUTE!
Oh, that was sooo cuuute...
Oh, that was so cute.
So you could, like,
I, I know this could probably be put to a challenge,
but I haven't thought of it yet,
I think it's just a fun experience, like,
just to go through and watch this, like,
It's so weird, it's like a combo:
Try not to cringe, try not to laugh, try not to smile challenge
You know what, I'm not gonna lump it into any of the other categories.
This Reddit--this sub-Reddit is just really cool.
and you guys can check it out.
So I'm gonna see a few more,
I'mna-I'mna browse the front page of it right now
and you can just watch along
"WoMaN riPs oFf LeG In hORriBle GyM AcCiDeNt!".
I don't remember seeing this, I don't know why it's blanked out.
(giggles)
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha.
"InNOcEnt dOG fUcKinG MaULeD bY aLBinO PanTHER".
(Wheeze, giggles) Awww
AhHHh fuck it's *giggles* a lot of it's animals just being cute
Ah frick
"MAn MaULEd tO deAtH bY PacK of StaRVEd BeaRS".
Ohh, this could go horribly wrong.
This could go horribly wrong.
Oh, why, why is he there?
That seems ju- seems like a terrible idea!
But it's cute, but also terrifying! Augh!
Good stuff, good stuff.
"BEAr brutally tearS FlaMINGo to PIeceS" *laughter*
Aww!
Aww proud mama!
Your baby got a kill!
Your baby's got something home!
Oh the bacon-bringer! *laughing*
Oh that's so cute!
Baby bears are so cute
Except they're fucking terrifying
"hEcKIN' sUICIDal DeLIVeRy bOy EnDs HiS oWn LiFE In A hIgH sPeEd HoRrIfIc mOtOrBiKe AcCiDeNt".
O-kay
Hmm
*Markimoo silently laughing*
Oh, stuff like that
Oh, where it's stuff like that
Where's its just bonk
And then it's a slow fall over
Aw fuck, I love - I love the clickbait sub-Reddit.
It's my favorite
"VicioUS dOG MAUls FrIendS FAce".
*cute reaction face*
aw
Aw it's so cute!
Oh no-ho-ho (giggles)
Your friend, Plank's cousin
Oh no he'll never recover
"CyBoRg dOg gOs oN a rAmPaGe, kIlLs tHe cAmErAmAn"
CyBoRg dOg gOs oN a rAmPaGe, kIlLs tHe cAmErAmAn
(gasp!)
Awwww
Mark: Awwww
oooH
OOOh!
OOOh
maSTER HAs giVEn DOBby a sOCK!
OOOOOOOH! (high pitched)
Ohhhh! (high pitched)
Ohhhh! (Now a lower one)
Oh, it's so happy!
Oh no! Ah, fuck. Imma cry,
*grunt*
Ah fuck
AAAAHAHhHHHhhaaaaaaaAAAAaAAAAAaaH
nnnnnn
nnnnnno.
nnnnnno
ah frick
ahh frick
uuugh god
(Mark turns into a horse)
That's what this is
Like this sub-Reddit is
It's a mixed bag
That's the thing
It's everything
it's everything all in one.
It's everything you could possibly hope for
it's all better for the context *laughs*
with it-- of which it's presented
Like, these videos, they're shown at other places
But, just in the specific, like apprehensive surprise
i don't know
it's just-- it's such a fun subreddit
"Bird GeTS EaTeN bY CrOc iN OnE BitE".
oh, ho ho ho (laughter)
It's so tiny *gigglyplier*
(high pitched) oh, it was so tiny!
ooOOooh.
"cHiLD EaTeN aLiVe By PaCk Of WoLvEs!".
*Markimoo laughter*
oooOh, STOP.
STop it, you.
Stop it.
SHTaP that!
you're too cute.
oh, don't do that.
oh, fuck off.
Oh this is too cute.
Oh my god that's amazing.
wait, i gotta-- i gotta see the last one.
"pSYCHoPATh ChoREOgRapHeR SuMMoNS tORnADO tO DeSTrOY ViLLagE".
*Mark laughs*
(laughter) I mean that's amazing but god it's so funny!
oh man, how do you not get dizzy? that's insanity
INSANITYY
God, it keeps going! Holy shit!
ok alright, enough, enough! You've already shown how much better you are than me and everybody else here!
eNOUGH! STOP!
Geezums.
Okay, there we go. Wow. Alright.
*mark groans*
So anyway! That is r/PeopleFuckingDying.
If you wanna go to the subreddit I'll put a link in the description below
It is a lovely place.
If you wanna smile or laugh or cry or go uGHH like-- there's a few grisly ones in here but it's never that bad
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think of this down in the comments below
And if you have a favorite subreddit of your own, let me know that as well!
because there's a ton of stuff out there, there's always good stuff
It's just like the literal thing is-- just the context.
It's the-It's the same thing in a new wrapper, and that's what makes it great.
So thank you again, and as always, I will see you, in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*outro music*